si santiago buenas tardes la verdad es
que no se esperaba
efectivamente recibía presión desde
todos los puntos dentro del partido el
propio presidente joe biden le había
recomendado que renunciara al cargo la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi también le
había insinuado que porque no renunciaba
al cargo y desde su entorno más cercano
también ejercían esa presión pero andrew
como este fin de semana de hecho decía
que necesitaba más tiempo y al parecer
de hecho si os fijáis cuándo comienza
esa rueda de prensa
toma de repente a mitad de rueda de
prensa un camino completamente distinto
cuando él asegura que va a renunciar
porque en todo momento ha negado que él
fuera consciente de eso de ese acoso
sexual que puso de manifiesto esa
investigación de la fiscal general del
estado de nueva york hace una semana esa
investigación se hizo pública y dijo que
había indicios de que el gobernador ha
yo como habría acosado sexualmente
sexualmente al menos a 11 mujeres así
que desde luego la noticia ha pillado
por sorpresa a todos los neoyorquinos a
todos los estadounidenses
amén que pasa ahora con lo que es el
proceso de impeachment que estaba
evaluando el comité de la asamblea de
nueva york
si santiago ayer la asamblea legislativa
del estado se reunió para valorar todos
los hechos para valorar esta
investigación de la fiscal general del
estado de nueva york y también la suya
propia que llevaban realizando desde
marzo el presidente de la asamblea
legislativa ha dicho que muy pronto se
tomará una decisión sobre si poner
encima de la mesa o no ese juicio
político es impeachment que tendrá que
ser votado por los legisladores basta
con una mayoría de 176 de esos 150
legisla todo de aisladores para que el
impeachment ese proceso político siga
adelante al parecer y en las últimas
encuestas que hemos visto la mayoría de
los legisladores estaban a favor de
llevar a cabo ese juicio político
siempre y cuando andrew como no
renunciar a su cargo ahora con este
cambio de rumbo que hemos visto habrá
que ver cuál es su reacción pero así así
mismo el presidente de esta asamblea
legislativa ha dejado muy claro que le
va a dar al gobernador andrew como hasta
el próximo 13 de agosto para presentar
cualquier prueba que pueda demostrar su
inocencia
amén sala muchísimas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde la ciudad de
nueva york